Hello and welcome to Speaking of Psychology, a podcast produced by the American Psychological Association. I'm your host, Audrey Hamilton. In this episode, I talk with a psychologist about how marketers and even job seekers can use the six universal principles of persuasion to be successful without being manipulative. So you see, very small changes in the way we communicate can produce big differences because those small changes are hard. powerful psychological motivations inside us. While psychologists have been able to uncover the subtle mechanics of persuasion, we also discuss how influencers can use the principles ethically, a tactic that will lead to more effective and longer-lasting behaviors.
您好，欢迎收听由美国心理学会制作的播客《心理学谈话》。我是主持人奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。在本期节目中，我将与一位心理学家探讨营销人员甚至求职者如何利用六大通用说服原则，在不进行操纵的情况下取得成功。你看，我们沟通方式中非常微小的改变就能产生巨大的差异，因为这些微小的改变利用了我们内心强大的心理动机。虽然心理学家已经揭示了说服的微妙机制，但我们也讨论了影响者如何合乎道德地使用这些原则，这是一种能带来更有效、更持久行为的策略。
Robert Chaldini has been the go-to psychology expert in marketing since his best-selling book, Influence, the Psychology of Persuasion, was first published in 1984. He is a Regents Professor Emeritus of Psychology and Marketing at Arizona State University, as well as CEO and president of the consulting company, Influence at Work, which focuses on ethical influence training. He recently published a new book called Presuasion, A Revolutionary Way to Influence and Persuade. Welcome, Dr. Chaldeenie. Thank you, Audrey. Good to be with you and your listeners.
罗伯特·西奥迪尼自 1984 年其畅销书《影响力：说服心理学》首次出版以来，一直是营销心理学领域的权威专家。他是亚利桑那州立大学心理学和营销学荣誉退休教授，也是咨询公司“影响力工作”（Influence at Work）的首席执行官兼总裁，该公司专注于道德影响力培训。他最近出版了一本新书，名为《预说服：影响与说服的革命性方式》。欢迎您，西奥迪尼博士。谢谢你，奥黛丽。很高兴能与你和你的听众交流。
All right. Well, let's first talk about the theory you're most associated with, which is the six. principles of persuasion? First of all, what are these six principles, if some of our listeners may not be familiar with them? And can you give them a brief description of what they are? Surely. The first is reciprocation, the idea that in all human societies, we are trained from childhood that we must give back to those who have given to us first. And we have very nasty names for people who don't play by those rules. We call them moochers or takers. or in grades. Nobody wants to be labeled like that. So we will go to great lengths to give back to
好的。那么，让我们先谈谈与您联系最紧密的理论，即六大说服原则。首先，如果有些听众不太熟悉，这六大原则是什么？您能简要描述一下它们吗？当然。第一个是互惠原则，即在所有人类社会中，我们从小就被训练：必须回报那些先给予我们帮助的人。对于那些不遵守这些规则的人，我们有非常难听的称呼。我们称他们为“蹭饭者”、“索取者”或“忘恩负义者”。没人想被贴上这样的标签。因此，我们会竭尽全力去回报那些给予我们帮助的人。
those who have given to us. There was a study done in a candy store in which half of the visitors were greeted by the manager who gave them a gift piece of chocolate upon entry. They were 42% more likely to buy candy. And not all of them bought chocolate. It wasn't that they learned that the chocolate there was good. It's that they had been given something and they felt an obligation to give back. A second principle is the principle of liking. No one will be surprised to know that we prefer to say yes to those we like. That's not a surprise. But the research suggests that there's a small thing we can do to get people to like us more. For example, waiters in a restaurant after the order is taken, if they say to a customer, good choice, their tip goes up 13%.
有一项在糖果店进行的研究显示，一半的顾客在进店时受到了经理的问候，并获赠了一块巧克力。结果，他们购买糖果的可能性增加了 42%。而且并非所有人都买了巧克力。并不是因为他们觉得那里的巧克力好吃，而是因为他们得到了东西，并感到有义务回报。第二个原则是喜好原则。没人会惊讶于我们更倾向于答应自己喜欢的人。这并不奇怪。但研究表明，我们可以做一件小事来让别人更喜欢我们。例如，在餐厅里，服务员在点完餐后如果对顾客说“好选择”，他们的小费会增加 13%。
Really? I've heard that quite a bit. No. In a hair salon, if the stylist says, oh, that hairstyle looks great on you, her tip goes up 37%. So simply giving genuine compliments where they're warranted can be. successful for all concerned. Another principle is the principle of what we call social proof. The idea that one way we can make good decisions is to see what those around us like us are doing in that situation. There was a study done in Beijing, China. It shows you the cross-cultural reach
真的吗？我经常听说这个。不。在美发沙龙里，如果造型师说“哦，那个发型很适合你”，她的小费会增加 37%。因此，在适当的时候给予真诚的赞美，对各方来说都是成功的。另一个原则是我们所说的社会认同原则。这个想法是，我们做出正确决策的一种方式是观察周围和我们相似的人在那种情况下是怎么做的。在中国北京进行了一项研究，这展示了该原则的跨文化影响。
of this principle. What they did was to go to restaurants and put on the menu of a little asterisk next to certain dishes. Purchasing of those dishes immediately jumped by 13 to 20%. Now, what did the asterisk stand for? It didn't say, this is the chef special for tonight, or this is the specialty of the house. It said, this is one of our most popular items. And it immediately became more popular because it was popular.
他们所做的是去餐厅，在菜单上某些菜品旁边加一个小星号。这些菜品的购买量立即增加了 13% 到 20%。那么，星号代表什么呢？它并没有写“这是今晚的主厨推荐”或“这是本店特色”。它写的是“这是我们最受欢迎的菜品之一”。因为它受欢迎，所以它立即变得更受欢迎了。
So social proof. Another principle is the principle of authority. We prefer to say yes to people who can give us evidence that experts on a topic have recommended the particular steps that they are asking us to take. So for example, in one study that my team did in how hospitals with stroke patients who were sent home with exercise regimens to do while they were at home. They were 30% more likely to live up to those exercise regimens if the person who gave them the exercise regimen had his credentials and diplomas on the wall when he did so. So this was an expert and people were more likely to follow the recommendation. because we typically are safe in following the lead of legitimate authorities.
这就是社会认同。另一个原则是权威原则。我们更倾向于答应那些能提供证据的人，证明某个领域的专家推荐了他们要求我们采取的特定步骤。例如，我的团队在医院进行的一项研究中，针对那些带着锻炼计划回家进行康复的中风患者。如果提供锻炼计划的人在给出建议时墙上挂着他的资历和文凭，患者坚持执行这些锻炼计划的可能性会增加 30%。所以这是一个专家，人们更愿意遵循建议，因为我们通常在遵循合法权威的引导时感到安全。
A fifth principle is the principle of scarcity. People want more of those things they can have less of. So there was one study in supermarkets that showed that of all the promotions that they did for the various brands on their stores, The one that outdistanced all the others by double was one that said only X number of items per customer. Okay. So if it's scarce, if it's rare, if it's dwindling in availability, we want it more. And then the final principle is commitment and consistency.
第五个原则是稀缺原则。人们想要那些他们能得到的东西越少越好。因此，超市里有一项研究表明，在他们为店内各种品牌所做的所有促销活动中，唯一一个以两倍优势领先于其他所有促销活动的是那些写着“每位顾客限购 X 件”的促销。好的。所以如果它是稀缺的，如果它是罕见的，如果它的供应量在减少，我们就会更想要它。最后一个原则是承诺和一致性。
People want to say yes to those requests that are consistent with that. the commitments they've already made. So, for example, in a Chicago restaurant, a big problem was no-shows. People who would call, make a reservation, and then not show for it. The owner of the restaurant tried a small technique that dramatically reduced no-shows. His receptionist used to say, thank you for calling Gordon's restaurant. Please call if you have to change or cancel your reservation. Instead, he asked her to say, will you please call if you have to change or cancel your reservation? And then to pause and let the person say, yes, of course. That produced the 67% drop in no-shows. So you see, very small changes in the way we communicate can produce big differences
人们想要答应那些与他们已经做出的承诺相一致的请求。例如，在芝加哥的一家餐厅，一个大问题是“爽约”。人们打电话预订，然后却不出现。餐厅老板尝试了一个小技巧，大大减少了爽约。他的接待员过去常说：“感谢您致电戈登餐厅。如果您需要更改或取消预订，请致电。”相反，他让她说：“如果您需要更改或取消预订，请您致电好吗？”然后停顿一下，让对方说“是的，当然”。这使得爽约率下降了 67%。所以你看，我们沟通方式中非常微小的改变就能产生巨大的差异，
because those small changes harness powerful psychological motivations inside us. Well, as I recently mentioned in the introduction, you recently published your latest book on something you called pre-suation. This is the idea you say of setting up a message before you send it to get the result you want. Can you explain more about what pre-suation is and what sort of research was conducted to demonstrate that this works? Surely. So where the book influence said, asked the question, what can a communicator put into a message to get people to say yes to it, right?
因为这些微小的改变利用了我们内心强大的心理动机。正如我刚才在介绍中提到的，您最近出版了关于您称之为“预说服”的最新著作。您说这是一种在发送信息之前进行铺垫以获得想要结果的想法。您能详细解释一下什么是预说服，以及进行了什么样的研究来证明它是有效的吗？当然。所以，如果说《影响力》一书问的是“沟通者可以在信息中加入什么来让人们答应它”，对吧？
These six principles. Presuasion asked the question, what can a communicator put into the moment before delivering the message that makes people more open and receptive to it? to make them agree with the message before they've encountered it. Well, that sounds like some kind of magic, doesn't it? Some mind. How do you get people to agree with something they don't know if they haven't heard yet? Right. Well, it's not magic.
这六大原则。而《预说服》问的是“沟通者可以在传递信息之前的瞬间加入什么，使人们更加开放和接受它？”即在人们接触到信息之前就让他们同意它。嗯，这听起来像某种魔法，不是吗？某种读心术。你怎么能让人们在还没听到内容的情况下就同意某件事呢？对。好吧，这不是魔法。
It's established science. and the key is if the communicator gets an individual to focus on a particular concept or idea that is the central aspect of the message that's yet to occur, people will now focus on that central aspect when they encounter it. They will have been sensitized to that kind of information. information. I'll give you an example, a research example. A study was done with an online furniture store. They specialized in sofas. Half of the visitors to their website encountered a landing page with fluffy clouds as the background wallpaper of that site. Those individuals then rated
这是既定的科学。关键在于，如果沟通者让个人专注于某个特定的概念或想法，而这个概念正是尚未发生的信息的核心方面，那么当人们遇到该信息时，他们现在就会专注于那个核心方面。他们会对这类信息变得敏感。我给你举一个研究例子。一项针对在线家具店的研究。他们专门销售沙发。访问他们网站的一半用户在着陆页上看到了以蓬松的云朵作为背景壁纸。那些人随后评价
comfort of sofas as more important to them. They searched the site for comfort-related features of the sofas and they preferred to purchase more comfortable furniture because the first thing they were focused on was softness in those clouds. Now, the other half of the visitors were sent to a site with small coins, pennies in the background wallpaper. They then rated price as a more important feature for them in buying a sofa. They searched the site for cost-related information, and they preferred to purchase more inexpensive furniture. So wherever they were sent first,
沙发的舒适度对他们来说更重要。他们在网站上搜索沙发的舒适相关功能，并且更倾向于购买更舒适的家具，因为他们首先关注的是云朵的柔软。现在，另一半访问者被引导到一个背景壁纸上有小硬币（便士）的网站。他们随后评价价格是他们购买沙发时更重要的特征。他们在网站上搜索与成本相关的信息，并且更倾向于购买更便宜的家具。所以无论他们首先被引导到哪里，
now they prioritize that idea, that concept, in what they encountered next. The interesting thing was that when they were asked afterwards, by the way, did that background on the landing page make any difference to you and how you chose? They laughed. They said, of course not. I'm a freestanding entity.
他们现在就会优先考虑那个想法、那个概念，并将其应用到他们接下来遇到的事物中。有趣的是，当他们事后被问到：“顺便问一下，着陆页上的那个背景对你的选择有什么影响吗？”他们笑了。他们说：“当然没有。我是个独立的个体。”
I make my decisions based on my internal preferences. They never recognized that their internal preferences had been shaped by what they saw first. Well, let's take this idea of persuasion. Let's say I'm going for a job interview, or maybe I'm asking my boss for a promotion or a raise. How do I set it up to get what I want? Let's take the job interview. That's a classic one. We typically go into a situation. There's an evaluator sitting across a table, sometimes more than one. And what we are typically trained to say is, thank you for inviting me. I want to be sure to answer all of the questions you have of my. me. Here's what I would recommend based on presuasion. We should say one more thing before the interview begins. But you know, I'm curious. I have a question for you. Why did you invite me here today? What was it about my candidacy that attracted you to me? Now what you will find as these
我根据自己的内在偏好做出决定。他们从未意识到他们的内在偏好已经被他们首先看到的东西所塑造。好吧，让我们谈谈这个说服的想法。假设我要去参加工作面试，或者我正在向老板申请晋升或加薪。我该如何铺垫以获得我想要的？让我们以工作面试为例。这是一个经典的例子。我们通常进入一个环境。桌子对面坐着一位评估员，有时不止一位。我们通常被训练说：“感谢您邀请我。我一定会回答您关于我的所有问题。”根据预说服，我建议在面试开始前多说一句话。但你知道，我很好奇。我有一个问题想问您。您今天为什么邀请我来这里？我的候选人资格中有什么吸引您的地方？现在你会发现这些
individuals will go into your resume focusing themselves on your strengths, all of the most positive things about your resume, your qualifications, and the interview will begin with that as the, as the, as the, uh, fundament. That's the frame of the interview, your strengths. Now, I have a acquaintance who claims he's gotten three straight better jobs in a row using this strategy, this persuasive strategy. It makes sense when you think about it. Yeah. Yeah.
个人会翻看你的简历，专注于你的优势，即你简历中最积极的所有方面、你的资格，面试将以此为基础开始。这就是面试的框架，你的优势。我有一个熟人声称他利用这种策略，这种说服策略，连续获得了三份更好的工作。当你仔细想想，这很有道理。是的。是的。
Why not, right? Why not? How can it hurt? How can it hurt? You're focusing people on your strengths. And also, when you hear them describe your strengths, you know what their values are, what the things they're interested in. looking for. Those are the reasons they brought you in. You can now embellish on those features of your
为什么不呢，对吧？为什么不呢？有什么坏处呢？有什么坏处？你让人们专注于你的优势。而且，当你听到他们描述你的优势时，你就知道他们的价值观是什么，他们正在寻找什么。这些就是他们邀请你来的原因。你现在可以进一步阐述你背景和资历中的这些特点。
background and credentials. Another thing I want to address is the idea of ethics and persuasion. You know, as a psychologist who instructs companies on how to persuade others, people, consumers, how do you convince them to do so without stepping over that ethical line into manipulation, let's say? Yes. Well, my team has recently completed. a piece of research on what happens to organizations that don't apply ethical rules to the way that they treat their customers, their clients, their prospects, and who are deceptive, dishonest in the presentation of that information. What happens is some people inside the organization, inside the company feel uncomfortable with this kind of duplicity, this requirement that they
我想讨论的另一件事是道德与说服的概念。你知道，作为一名指导公司如何说服他人（消费者）的心理学家，你如何说服他们这样做而不越过道德界限进入操纵领域呢？是的。好吧，我的团队最近完成了一项研究，关于那些不对对待客户、客户、潜在客户的方式应用道德规则，并且在信息呈现中具有欺骗性、不诚实的组织会发生什么。发生的情况是，组织内部、公司内部的一些人对这种虚伪感到不舒服，这种要求他们
be dishonest as part of their job. It creates emotional distress in them. They're agitated, they're upset by having to do this. And our research shows, as a consequence, they perform their jobs less well because they're upset, they're more likely to leave the organization, which creates big turnover costs for any company that chooses an unethical approach. But thirdly, when those people who are uncomfortable with cheating leave and what's left is a precipitate of employees who are comfortable, with cheating, we find they will cheat the company. The company has selected for dishonest people. Those people who lie for you will lie to you. These will be the people who pad their expense accounts,
在工作中必须不诚实。这给他们造成了情绪困扰。他们因为不得不这样做而感到焦虑、不安。我们的研究表明，结果是他们工作表现变差，因为他们感到不安，他们更有可能离开组织，这给任何选择不道德方法的公司带来了巨大的人员流动成本。但第三，当那些对欺骗感到不舒服的人离开后，剩下的就是一群对欺骗感到自在的员工，我们发现他们会欺骗公司。公司筛选出了不诚实的人。那些为你撒谎的人也会对你撒谎。这些人会虚报费用，
who run under the table deals with vendors and suppliers, who steal equipment and so on. So it's against their own best interest and bottom line. That's exactly right, Audrey. This is the reason why when I speak to leaders of various organizations, I tell them that they should be scrupulously honest. Anything less is going to drive away their most honest employees and give them the headache of having to manage dishonest employees inside their organizational envelope.
与供应商进行暗箱操作，偷窃设备等等。所以这违背了他们自己的最大利益和底线。完全正确，奥黛丽。这就是为什么当我与各组织的领导者交谈时，我告诉他们应该极其诚实。任何低于这个标准的做法都会赶走他们最诚实的员工，并给他们带来不得不管理组织内部不诚实员工的头痛问题。
So circling back to the original six principles that we talked about at the beginning, how can people recognize when someone is using them unethically or being manipulative? Yes. Sometimes you can't tell until the transaction is over and you realize that you've been fooled or duped or not fully informed. You know, we in my company, we sometimes have technological issues that need to be solved, and we need to contract somebody who comes in to solve them, and people will claim expertise. Oh, yes, we can do this.
那么回到我们开头谈到的最初的六大原则，人们如何识别别人何时在不道德地使用它们或进行操纵？是的。有时在交易结束之前你无法分辨，直到你意识到自己被愚弄、欺骗或没有得到充分的信息。你知道，在我的公司，我们有时会遇到需要解决的技术问题，我们需要聘请某人来解决它们，人们会声称拥有专业知识。哦，是的，我们可以做到。
We have a long history of being able to solve this particular problem. And then we find out that was just to get us to sign the contract. They claim to have authority when they didn't. and as a consequence, our only redress is to say, we will never do business with you again. We will never testify. We will never give a testimonial in your behalf. In fact, we'll tell all our friends not to do business with you. That's the long-term consequence of the unethical use of these strategies.
我们有解决这个特定问题的悠久历史。然后我们发现那只是为了让我们签署合同。他们声称拥有权威，但实际上并没有。结果，我们唯一的补救措施就是说：“我们再也不会与你们做生意了。我们永远不会作证。我们永远不会为你们提供推荐信。事实上，我们会告诉我们所有的朋友不要与你们做生意。”这就是不道德使用这些策略的长期后果。
Now, that's not to say that people who use these strategies. strategies always use them dishonestly. The last time I bought a television set, I was in an appliance store. I wasn't really looking for a new TV, but I saw a great deal on a big screen TV that I knew had been rated very well by consumer reports, and a salesman came up to me, said, I see you're interested in this set here. I can understand why. That's a great price for that model. But I should tell you, that's our last one. And I just got a call from a woman to say that she might be in today. To get it.
现在，这并不是说使用这些策略的人总是以不诚实的方式使用它们。上次我买电视机时，我在一家电器商店。我并不是真的在找新电视，但我看到一台大屏幕电视价格非常优惠，我知道它被《消费者报告》评级很高，一位推销员走过来对我说：“我看到你对这台电视感兴趣。我能理解为什么。这个型号的价格很棒。但我应该告诉你，这是我们最后的一台了。我刚接到一位女士的电话，说她今天可能会来买它。”
To get it. Audrey, 20 minutes later, I'm wheeling out of the store with that set in my cart. And I'm the guy who wrote the book on this. I'm still susceptible to it, right? Right. Now, here. Here's what I did the following day. I went back to that store to see if that set was still an empty space on the shelf.
来买它。奥黛丽，20分钟后，我推着购物车带着那台电视机离开了商店。而我就是写那本书的人。我仍然容易受到它的影响，对吧？对。现在，这是我第二天做的事情。我回到那家商店，看看那台电视机是否还在货架上的空位上。
Was it really the last one? Or had they just gone to the storeroom and replaced it with another? And that scarcity principle was being exploited to get me to comply. It wasn't a genuine piece of information that I could use to improve my outcomes in the situation. It turns out there was an empty. space. It was true. So here's what I did. I went back to my office. I went online and I provided a customer review that praised that store and that salesperson because in that situation, he was not my, he was not my enemy. He was my ally in the process of getting something good by giving
它真的是最后的一台吗？还是他们只是去储藏室又拿了一台出来？那个稀缺原则被利用来让我顺从。这不是我可以用来改善我在那种情况下结果的真实信息。结果发现确实有一个空位。那是真的。所以我做了什么？我回到办公室。我上网并提供了一个客户评论，赞扬了那家商店和那位推销员，因为在那种情况下，他不是我的敌人。他是我的盟友，通过给我关于真实稀缺性的诚实信息，帮助我获得好东西。
me honest information about true scarcity. Under those circumstances, I was happy to partner with him. Well, thank you, Dr. Cheldini, for joining us. It was a pleasure to have you. Well, I enjoyed the opportunity as well. Thanks for listening to our podcast. Make sure you check out our other episodes of Speaking of Psychology, and please subscribe if you haven't already.
在这种情况下，我很乐意与他合作。好吧，谢谢西奥迪尼博士加入我们。很高兴有您参加。嗯，我也很享受这次机会。感谢收听我们的播客。请务必查看我们《心理学谈话》的其他剧集，如果您还没有订阅，请订阅。
We are a proud member of the APA Podcast Network, which includes other great podcasts. Please check out APA Journal's Dialogue. if you want to hear about the latest and most exciting psychology research. And if you're interested in the practice of psychology, you can listen to Progress Notes. Topics include how health care policy and social media affect practicing psychologists. You can find those podcasts on iTunes, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. You can also go to our website, Speaking of Psychology.org, to listen to even more episodes and gather more resources on the topics we discussed.
我们是美国心理学会播客网络的骄傲成员，该网络还包括其他优秀的播客。如果您想了解最新、最令人兴奋的心理学研究，请查看《美国心理学会期刊对话》。如果您对心理学实践感兴趣，可以收听《进度记录》。主题包括医疗保健政策和社交媒体如何影响执业心理学家。您可以在 iTunes、Stitcher 或任何您获取播客的地方找到这些播客。您也可以访问我们的网站 SpeakingofPsychology.org，收听更多剧集并收集有关我们讨论主题的更多资源。
Thanks for joining us. I'm Audrey Hamilton with the American Psychology. Psychological Association, and this is Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢您的加入。我是美国心理学会的奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这是《心理学谈话》。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。